certain loss retaliation the book of the
Samurai after a long wait fans finally
got another glorious look at the Baba
Yaga with the return of Keanu Reeves and
the fourth and possibly final
installments of his Blockbuster
franchise John Wick chapter four more
the film brought us everything we knew
we would see like beautiful set pieces
and action sequences and clubs to enough
bullets to overtake a small country and
also brought some surprises from the
destruction of Winston's Continental
Hotel to the scene in the final moments
that everyone is talking about the
apparent death of John Wick now Reeves
has explained that was the plan the
Moment the movie came about even saying
it was the entire point of the film
after three films are being shot stamped
hanged hit by cars and left in the
desert to die fans began to get the
feeling that our beloved Boogeyman
killer was indestructible that is when
the filmmakers through the curveball
that fans weren't expecting that is
obviously the very first thing that
Reeves had to answer for when a fan
asked him about the ending according to
the Hollywood Reporter Reeves spoke
about what may made him and directed
Chad stahlski want to make yet another
John Wick besides just the fans wanting
one he said what was the why and when
Chad and I was talking that y was death
and it was John Wick's death for him to
get his peace or freedom in a way that
was the reason to make the movie it
can't just be let's do another one it
was really about death or a way of dying
we were really inspired by the Hagar
Curry Hagar karei also known as the book
of the Samurai is a collection of
teachings for warriors while the setting
of the final film took place partly in
Japan as a fitting tribute to their
inspiration the book itself seems to
have been a common theme throughout the
entirety of the franchise there are
quotes throughout the writing that seem
to imply perfectly to the world of the
continental and of course Royal John
Wick this quote from the book feels as
though it is the core center of the
entire franchise even if it seems
certain that you will lose retaliate
what began as a simple quest for revenge
for the killing of one dog ballooned
into one man fighting an unwinnable
battle against sensing Force through
four films John was never supposed to
win and eventually he would find his end
at the hands of the life he led the book
continues even if you are aware that you
may be struck down today and are firmly
resolved to an inevitable death if you
are slain with an unseemly appearance he
will show your lack of previous resolve
will be despised by your enemy and will
appear unclean of course the Bowery King
references quote Best when offering up a
crisp black suit to Jon when he
commented that every man should look his
best on the day that he is married and
the day that he is buried John always
fought in a suit likely because it was
ballistic and shielded him from The
Barrage of bullets constantly fight his
way but there is something to be said
about looking your best even when doing
your worst death is everywhere in the
John Wick franchise from Jon's past as a
harbinger of human exploration and his
wife's devastating death at the hands of
an illness to his unending quest to
destroy everything in his path it seems
there was no other way to end this
franchise in his own moment of finding
peace in his death John was a man living
purely driven by one Mission and once
accomplished there wouldn't seem to be
anywhere else for him to go and Jon
isn't the only character whose death
found a fitting and emotional end the
character of Sharon was killed in the
early minutes of the film with a
gut-wrenching it's been a pleasure at it
to Winston that moment hit heavily
knowing that actor Lance Reddick passed
away only days before the premiere the
moment of an on-screen death echoing a
real-life death brought the theme and
the ending more meaning even if that
particular angle was devastatingly
unintentional this quote from a guy
curate is a defining theme for all of
the franchise The Way of the Samurai is
found in death Jonas established himself
as one of the greatest warriors in
cinematic history and with ties to the
Japanese culture with Osaka playing a
big part in the final film the samurai
view on death represents the only path
that could realistically be taken
watching the man we grew to believe to
be indestructible over the last decade
Dai was undoubtedly one of the most
emotional and gut-wrenching moments
Reeves has delivered birth when his
future is considered on the Prospect of
survival a life without his wife and
constant pain and suffering and grief
this ending seems fitting it is
ultimately what the samurai calls a good
death
[Music]